the reluctance to compare what's going
on now to what happened in nazi germany
is not just a concern
about um
trampling insensitively
on the horrors of what happened to the
jewish people and other people in 1930s
and 40s germany it's not just a moral
transgression
i think the concern is that maybe the
underlying concern
is with
as soon as we make an analogy between
what's happening now in any moment in
the past we're forcing a connection that
we've really lost already
and we don't know how to do it
yeah i i take this one very personally
um i was born in 1969 which at the time
seemed a long way from
nazi germany and i now realize it wasn't
very long at
all and you know as a jewish kid
my elders
made very sure
that my generation understood that it
could happen here it can happen anywhere
and you probably thought they were crazy
no i listened
what i didn't get what i never once
thought
was that it could happen everywhere
right i always thought
it can happen somewhere and the thing is
you don't want to be late
to escape it
i didn't think it was going to happen
everywhere but
i know that over all those
years we've developed a sensitivity to
analogizing that the holocaust has
become too sacred in a sense that we're
not allowed to invoke it because people
have been too careless in doing so
but my feeling is
a lot of people are now comforted by the
fact that what they see
doesn't look like nazi germany it
doesn't goose step it doesn't wear
skulls on its hats
right it's there's something comforting
about the fact that it doesn't look nazi
but i don't think we should be comforted
at all
because let's put it this way i don't
know the devil what is the saying the
devil you don't see is a lot worse than
the one that you do something like that
i mean the idea that it's almost sort of
hiding in plain sight or something
right hiding in plain sight hiding in
the form of tony fauci who just really
doesn't look like a nazi
right
but
the thing that spooks me
is
that when i go looking for analogies for
the forced vaccination program for
example
it doesn't land exactly on tuskegee
it doesn't land exactly on mangala
but i know that that's the quadrant of
the library that i'm forced to search
right right that there is no better
analogy and i think my my sense is
a
i think
because of the
history of persecution for jews that
jews have an obligation actually to
speak to this point and that if anybody
is allowed to violate the rules about
invoking the holocaust it ought to be us
that that's something we've earned
and i think my point is look i'm not
saying this is exactly that
but i am saying anytime you are forced
into that part of the library to look
for analogies
that's that's nature's way of telling
you something has gone very seriously
wrong
and i know
i know that's the quadrant of the
library i know it's that quadrant and i
know that in the fiction it's 1984. it's
brazil it's kafka
it's fahrenheit 451.
anytime you are forced into that
quadrant of the library you need to
think very carefully about how you got
there and what you could do
to undo it
[Music]